(upbeat music)
(crowd cheering)
- [Narrator] This is the
hottest sports ticket
in China right now.
Thousands of people
from across the country
are cramming into an outdoor stadium
to watch this grassroots basketball league
that's become a nationwide phenomenon.
We traveled to a remote mountain village
in the country's southwest,
the hometown of China's answer to the NBA.
- The scene here rivals what you'll see
in a lot of pro basketball
games all across China.
- [Narrator] The Cun-BA
or the Village Basketball
Association, provides a window
into China's passion
for the American sport
and has even attracted the attention
of professional NBA stars.
(crowd cheering)
These amateur games, which
run well into the night
have blown up on social media in China.
(crowd cheering)
We look at how this basketball court
has become one of the few
places where the US and China,
amid spiraling relations,
share common a ground.
(gentle music)
Taipan Village is a small rural
village of just 1,200 people
in one of China's poorest
provinces, Gujiao.
- There's no reason why you ever would've
heard of this village, and in fact,
most Chinese people had never heard of it
until a couple of weeks or months ago.
(crowd cheering)
- [Narrator] And now it's
become one of the hottest spots
in China, because of the Cun-BA.
(crowd cheering)
(speaking in foreign language)
- And it's really taken off here in China
not just in this village here
but all across this country
of 1.4 billion people.
In Beijing and Shanghai,
all the big cities
have been tuning in watching live streams
on the Chinese version of TikTok
and it's really gone viral.
(upbeat music)
(speaking in foreign language)
One of the things that
makes this Cun-BA so special
is that none of these
players are professional
but what's so good about them
and what people love is the passion here.
Another reason that the Cun-BA stands out
is it breaks the norm in
China's top-down sports system.
(crowd cheering)
You have a system that
identifies athletes of promise
early on in their lives and
nurtures them through the system
often pays for their training.
This is totally different,
what you see here
this is amateur basketball.
(gentle music)
And part of the appeal here
is not just the basketball
it's about the whole
festival atmosphere here.
It's like a big karaoke night.
They're doing singing,
there's dancing, there's games
there's all sorts of fun and festivities.
(speaking in foreign language)
(upbeat music)
(crowd cheering)
The electric atmosphere here
it's even attracted some
attention in the NBA.
Jimmy Butler of Miami Heat,
fresh off his NBA finals appearance
was here to take in these matches himself.
He put on a traditional
ethnic minority outfit
and took the mic at the
center of the stage.
(speaking in foreign language)
(crowd cheering)
- [Narrator] Stephon
Marbury, a former NBA star
now coaching in China's
professional league
visited Taipan Village recently
to draw attention to the potential talent
playing here in the countryside.
(speaking in foreign language)
- [Stephon] This can possibly
open up opportunities
for players who do play
in the Village League
for them to be able to get looked at
that need to be able to play
professional basketball for China.
(upbeat music)
- [Narrator] Basketball is one of those
quintessentially American sports
and this is a time of US-China tensions.
And yet, you don't feel that at all.
People here love the NBA
(crowd cheering)
Amid rising geopolitical tensions
this basketball court in Taipan Village
remains a rare arena of consensus
for the two superpowers.
(crowd cheering)
(upbeat music)